how great would it be if you could
memorize foreign language words and
expressions quickly and easily without
having to waste time with flashcards or
endless vocabulary lists Once Upon a
Time this might have seemed impossible
but today it's something anyone can do
so long as they follow the right
strategies today in this video I'll
share these strategies with you so that
your vocabulary learning can go from a
difficult chore to something you
actually look forward to and enjoy hi
I'm Lucas I'm a Language Coach who
speaks 14 languages and on this channel
I help people learn foreign languages
faster more efficiently and in a fun way
let's get started
vocabulary memorization is one of the
main challenges facing any language
learner no matter if your target
language is similar to your mother
tongue or quite distant from it you'll
have to figure out how to take tens of
thousands of words or expressions and
get them into your long-term memory
correctly to be quite honest most people
do not have a lot of luck with this they
stick to old and inefficient
memorization techniques they probably
learn from high school language class
and never learn that there are much
better and much less painful ways to get
the job done I'm going to give you an
overview of a few strategies that will
help you tap into the world of more
effective memorization we'll start with
three for today these strategies are
learn vocabulary through repeated
exposure to the right content use your
listening skills to learn and to review
and use new vocabulary for Meaningful
communication
one learn vocabulary through repeated
exposure to the right content like most
people I once thought that learning
words in a foreign language was all
about repetition to add a word to your
vocabulary I thought you had to write it
down and review it countless times over
and over and over again until it's stuck
in my mind that's how School tells us
the process goes and most people tend to
believe it but lately I've been focusing
on a last common memorization technique
one that does not involve any mindless
repetition whatsoever instead the
technique revolves around one thing
repeated exposure in context those last
two words in context are the most
important normally when you review words
using vocabulary lists and flashcards
you're getting exposure to those words
or Expressions out of context in other
words you're seeing the word itself and
not the many situations and sentences in
which you would normally see it appear
reviewing words in context is about
always seeing the word in its natural
habits so to speak if you see it again
and again within the right kinds of
content you'll memorize it automatically
without having to resort to vocab lists
or flash card this is what I do myself
and what I recommend to other Learners
seek out content that has three
characteristics content that is Rich
comprehensible and compelling Rich
content is content that you partially do
not understand this means that it
contains words that you can learn and
therefore add to your vocabulary over
time
comprehensible content is content that
you mostly do understand the words you
already know will help you figure out
the meaning of those Rich words you do
not know often without even using a
dictionary and compelling content is
content that is interesting and relevant
to you it connects with your interests
hobbies and passions and so you can
actually feel compelled to learn from it
once you identify content that contains
these three characteristics Circle
highlight or underline any words or
phrases from that content that you think
you will want to use for the future
since that content is Rich
comprehensible and compelling the words
within that content will automatically
be much easier to memorize simply
through seeing them or hearing them in
various podcasts videos or texts so
that's my lesson for you if you get
massive exposure to good content in your
target language your brain will
gradually and automatically build an
intricate web of patterns and
connections when you learn your words
from that content they will become a
part of the web and will be much more
likely to stick in your head two use
your listening skills to learn and
review
consuming content that is interesting
rich and engaging is a powerful practice
and it's exactly where you should start
your effective memorization process
however it's far from the only thing you
can do to make sure vocabulary sticks to
your long-term memory in fact while you
do need to keep consuming new content it
is also important to find creative
efficient and effortless ways to review
the content you have already learned
while you're moving on to new content
you haven't covered yet in other words
find the perfect balance between going
through new material and learning all
material and you will be able to improve
your ability to both learn and memory in
this regard a lot of people use
flashcards for vocabulary lists their
Resort is something called spaced
repetition and apps or space repetition
systems or srs's for short to Briefly
summarize the concept space repetition
is a memorization technique that
somewhat resembles how most people use
flashcards but with a Twist following
traditional memorization methods you
might learn a series of words and then
decide to write them all down on
flashcards then you might decide to to
go through the Deco flashcards from top
to bottom each day as a form of review
space repetition changes up this formula
by adjusting the intervals over which
you review each card if you test
yourself on a word and remember
correctly you would increase your review
interval allowing more time to pass
before you review that card again by
contrast if you test yourself in a word
that you cannot remember it you would
decrease the review interval and perhaps
review that card sooner than the others
in the deck by allowing yourself more
time to possibly forget the words you
think you know well you're actually
strengthening your memory of those words
if you can review something just before
your brain forgets it you will increase
your ability to actively recall it over
the long term there are entire apps that
automate this process for you Anki is
the most popular example but if you
followed my more recent videos you know
that using Anki is not something I
recommend instead I prefer a more manual
approach which simply involves taking
content you have already learned and
regularly listening to it a random
interval
this engages the core neurological
principles behind space repetition
without forcing you to navigate clanky
flashcard software like Anki here's how
it works as part of your daily learning
time make sure you do at least these two
things one dedicate one chunk of time to
learning a brand new listening or
listening and reading content that
you've never seen before and two
dedicate another chunk of time to
re-listening to content that you've gone
through previously no sitting down no
reading no writing just listening plain
and simple this allows you to re-listen
to the vocabulary in context and also
gives you a powerful review activity you
can do anywhere you have access to your
computer or your phone and possibly a
pair of headphones for example I like to
listen to Hungarian podcasts while going
grocery shopping and Greek podcasts
while I take my regular walks in a
nearby park it is a useful habit that
will give your brain ample opportunity
to gain repeated exposure to previously
learned words and phrases just like
space repetition systems do the
advantage here though is that this
practice which I call listening to
review keeps your reviewed language
material connected to its natural
context this allows you to use context
cues to strengthen your memory of
learned words and expressions much more
easily
three use new vocabulary for Meaningful
communication
so repeated exposure to target language
words in context is one of the most
powerful ways to build your vocabulary I
still stand by that lesson
wholeheartedly but the truth is that
it's only one piece of a much larger
puzzle there are still many other things
you can do and should do in order to
make words and phrases sticking your
mind this time my lesson on vocabulary
is a little bit more advanced and it's
all about how you can take things to the
next level during and after you've
regularly been exposed to new and
interesting words
to do that you need to engage in
something I call Smart review at first
my use of the word review here might
remind you of the review you did in
school where you would just mindlessly
revisit content and topics you had
covered earlier in the school year
likely in the very same way you did the
first time but that's just regular
run-of-the-mill review and it's hardly
effective smart review by contrast is
much much better and a heck of a lot
more fun to review vocabulary in a smart
way you need to make a habit of actively
using the words and expressions you'll
learn so not by rereading them or even
repeatedly writing them down those are
passive things but by using them for
Meaningful communication and what do I
mean by meaningful communication I mean
using the word phrase or expression to
communicate with another person either
verbally or in writing this sounds
harder than it actually is while you
might be imagining having to use the
word perfectly in a live Dynamic off the
cough conversation you do not need to
set your signs so high at least at first
even at the early stages of your
learning you can use learn words for
Meaningful Communication in simple ways
for example sending a short text message
to a native speaker friend that contains
a recently learned expression or two
recording a short voice message about a
video or podcast you recently found and
using new vocabulary in your short
summary of the content having a pretend
conversation with yourself where you try
to verbally summarize some language
material you recently covered all of
these are interesting and nuanced ways
to make active use of new expressions
and their effectiveness goes far beyond
the more common review strategies of
rereading and repeatedly rewriting words
over and over and the best part is that
they help you engage with native
speakers even as you review
so there you have it three powerful
strategies you can start using today to
memorize words and expressions in any
language let's quickly review these
points one learn vocabulary through
repeated exposure to the right content
two use your listening skills to learn
and to review and three use new
vocabulary for Meaningful communication
okay that's all for this video if you'd
like to learn more about my favorite
memorization strategies including the
listen to review and smart review
techniques check out my become a master
language learner courses where I go into
these methods and more in a lot more
detail if you're interested I've left
more information for you in the
description box below thanks for
watching and as always happy language
learning